♪ ♪ ♪
- Jorane, merci ououous
accueillir dans votre lieu
de création. C'est ici
que vous avez réalisé
en partie "Hemenetset".
- Oui!
- Votre mégaprojet,
6 ans de travail.
- ♪ Ah ♪
- J'ai vu les images
du dererer spectacle.
C'est assez grandiose.
- Oui.
- Effets visuels.
Vous êtes costumée...- - - Oui!
- Que vous vouliez-vous faire
avec ça?
JORANE, chanteuse
et violoncelliste
- Je voulais pousser à
l'extrême, si on veut,
les émotions qu'on pouvait
ressentir en musique.
Je voulais qu'on puisse voir
la musique. Oui, musicalement,
ce spectacle-là, sans aucun
effet, on peut le jouer.
Mais j'avais envie d'offrir
aussi aux musiciennes et
aux musiciens la possibilité
d'être autrement sur scène.
Tout le monde a accepté de
sortir de sa zone de confort.
Pour moi, c'était important
pour ce spectacle-là,
le projet en fait, de réunir,
un, plusieurs formes d'art;
deux, la technologie d'avant-
garde; et trois, le sens
du rituel, de la communion.
♪ ♪ ♪
Non, c'est ça, j'utilise
beaucoup la voix
comme un instrument.
- Ça, c'est intéressant
ce que vous dites,
parce que la première fois
que je vous ai rencontrée,
vous aviez un loft à Montréal.
Vous viviez vraiment
pour la musique.
- Oui.
- Pas trop d'argent.
Mais, très jeune,
vous saviez exactement
où vous vous en alliez, là.
- C'est très drôle, parce que
je fais un à-côté, mais...
Ce loft-là, je n'avais qu'une
plante et mon violoncelle.
Et juste avant, quand
j'habitais encore à Québec,
c'était la même chose :
j'avais une chaise,
mon violoncelle, un petit frigo.
J'ai toujours adoré avoir
un endroit totalement vide
seulement pour pouvoir
pratiquer mon violoncelle.
C'est comme ça que j'ai vécu,
oui, mes premières années
alors que j'étais encore
en étude en violoncelle.
Et... c'est drôle, parce que
pendant la COVID, j'ai dû
m'isoler. Et j'étais ici,
sur un matelas et j'étais
toute tellement heureuse
de pouvoir dormir à côté
des guitares, du piano,
comme dans le temps.
Il y a eu un moment en moi, là,
j'ai fait : Oh! mais je suis
très contente en ce moment,
d'avoir ce moment-là!
C'est très drôle.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Vous partagez votre vie
depuis près de 20 ans avec
Éloi Painchaud d'Okoumé,
anciennement, mais maintenant
avec Salebarbes.
- Oui!
- Comment l'un et l'autre vous
vous nourrissez musicalement?
- Oh... on est... Éloi et moi,
on peut toujours parler musique.
Il nous arrive de jouer
du cajun lui et moi, ensemble,
le soir en bas de laine.
- Ah oui?
- Oui. Hmm... En fait, on est
toujours le premier témoin
de ce que l'autre a composé.
Puis, c'est toujours
un moment super important.
Quand on dit : "OK, là,
c'est prêt. Viens écouter.
J'aimerais ça te faire
entendre quelque chose."
Puis, on a appris avec
les années aussi à...
à écouter de la bonne façon
les premières idées,
parce que c'est tellement...
c'est des moments fragiles.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Vous êtes porte-parole
depuis peu pour l'organisme
Le Phare Enfants et Familles,
qui vient en aide aux enfants
gravement malades et à leur
famille. Et ça vous touche, ça,
parce que votre premier garçon,
Manolo...
- Oui.
- Il a 15 ans, il est atteint
d'une maladie dégénérative.
Et j'ai l'impression que cette
épreuve a teinté votre musique.
- C'est sûr que notre
premier enfant, parce qu'on a
trois garçons. Le premier,
on l'a eu vraiment... pouf!
dans la face, dans le coeur.
Parce qu'on a été,
dans les premières semaines,
mis à l'épreuve, vraiment
avec... avec une situation
qui pouvait vraiment...
bien... sa vie se jouait
à tout bout de champ.
Alors, on a habité dans
les hôpitaux, vraiment,
dans les premières années
de notre vie avec Manolo.
J'ai dû, oui, annuler
des tournées, et j'avais pas
le choix. Et c'était pas...
il y a pas de question
pour moi à ce niveau-là.
J'avais toujours dit que
j'adapterais ma carrière
à ma vie de famille.
C'est ce que j'ai fait.
Maintenant que la menace
plane de plus haut,
ça me permet de pouvoir donner
au Phare Enfants et Familles,
cet élan pour faire connaître
cet endroit-là à tout le monde.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les enfants grandissent.
- Oui.
- Vous allez maintenant pouvoir
repartir en tournée?
- Ouais.
- Et là, il y a le gala des prix
Juno, le 15 mai prochain.
- Oui!
- Vous êtes en nomination
dans la catégorie
"meilleur album instrumental".
- Oui.
- Une victoire, ça pourrait
changer beaucoup de choses
pour vous?
- Mais déjà, déjà cette
nomination, pour moi,
m'offre une grande visibilité.
J'ai déjà des gens qui
m'ont écrit à qui j'avais pas
parlé depuis 15 ans,
qui me félicitent.
Alors déjà, cette nomination-là
me fait énormément plaisir.
- Alors, Jorane, je vous
souhaite tout le meilleur
pour le 15 mai prochain.
Merci beaucoup.
- Oui, merci!
♪ ♪